on your way to the office a message
comes in from your boss can you grab
them A coffee
they pay you back in a different app you
go to another app to place an order for
pickup and your mobile wallet needs to
be updated
okay there
now copy which took four apps to
accomplish but in China it takes just
one WeChat a super app you just don't
have to fuss around with your phone
remembering different passwords opening
and closing different apps it just makes
it easy so why isn't there a super app
in the US my idea would be like how
about if we just copy WeChat
though some apps have multiple functions
creating a super app in the US is the
Holy Grail for some tech CEOs and for
good reason
take another look at WeChat
the app launched in 2011 as a social
media and messaging service by the next
year it added a PayPal like payment
option and in the following years it
would integrate a slew of other features
including games shopping food delivery
Healthcare and mini apps it really sort
of does everything in some ways it's a
stand-in for the internet itself and
users liked it by 2022 WeChat had 1.3
billion active users and helped its
parent company bring in a revenue of
about 81 billion dollars the beauty of a
super app is that you're able to move
seamlessly between different functions
share information and data between the
different parts of that super app that's
what makes it work and that data is the
big draw for companies
let's look back at the apps you used to
make that coffee order again
apps in the US are largely restricted
from tracking you across your phone so
each company is only collecting data
while their app is open but with WeChat
you don't have to leave it to make that
order or message your boss or even post
a photo of that coffee on social media
that one company gets your data for all
of it having a better understanding of
what people are purchasing when they're
purchasing those things you know that
becomes invaluable for a business
um or if you're a government for you
know tax purposes that's one of the
reasons why companies from multiple
Industries in the US have made attempts
at creating their super app but their
growth has been slowed by several things
a super app in the U.S would have to
contend against thousands of other apps
and changing consumer Behavior can be
difficult we're not really used to using
one app for everything and that's why
when companies like Facebook in the past
have tried to Launch
singular apps that do more than one
thing at a time consumers have largely
rejected them Facebook Messenger said it
would simplify its app back in 2018
after adding features like games its
head at the time said that the app had
become too cluttered another key issue
is incorporating a payment system take
snap for example its payment system
snapcash shut down after four years
while apps like venmo and Zell were
growing if you can integrate that
payment system into a super app it just
makes that app much more sticky but it
also means in most cases that you can
control the transaction costs maybe
you're making a better margin in the
transaction and Azure user base grows
you you start to scale but integrating
that payment system is a big lift in the
US a lot of tech companies aren't also a
financial services company right out of
the box it's complicated there's
regulations involved there's different
International rules and things like that
Facebook's attempt at integrating a
crypto payment system failed in part
because lawmakers and Regulators were
concerned about payments being used for
illicit activity the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau has cracked down on
big Tech platforms using Payment Systems
in recent years
and data privacy can also become a
concern for consumers and lawmakers
right now a lot of people distrust the
big tech companies and the idea of a
single tech company like a meta or an
Amazon or a Google offering us an app
that really houses so many different
things from online payments to Bill
management
to health records you know it is kind of
scary to people and that becomes an
issue for companies I don't think at
this point technology companies are
interested in making it look like they
are consolidating their control over our
digital lives any more than they already
have I mean that would just invite
regulatory scrutiny some experts and
analysts think the future for super apps
in the US may look different than WeChat
I think the path forward for the super
app Concept in the United States has
more to do with verticals than sort of a
one ring to rule them all so for example
a single healthcare app might house your
medical information as well as features
for making appointments and payments
the first Champion that emerges and
creates a seamless frictionless super
app-like program that allowed doctors to
plug in their data you know electronic
health records stuff I think that that
is going to be a huge huge game changer
a massive disrupter
foreign
[Music]